i could chat with our guests for
hours but sometimes we only have a short
amount of time to spend with them during
the show
so here's the bonus moment we didn't
want you to miss
did you feel like going from being
a kid yeah to them being an adult like
was that
that must have been a strange transition
to be like and now i'm a
different human i really did and i had
sort of a
you know i i i was a kid and then i had
a really you know difficult time and
then nobody wanted to hire me because of
that it was sort of like a blacklisting
situation
okay you know 13 and you're like wow
okay i didn't see that coming and then
you look at your behavior you're like
yep i did see that coming actually
um okay perfect i'm gonna go and like
figure myself out and then when i came
back
as a teenager i was only 16 and going on
auditions and everyone was like well
that's that kind of washed up kid
and the kid word kept coming into play
and i was like what can i do to prove to
people i'm not a kid anymore
oh i know and i did like poison ivy and
bad girls and amy fisher and all these
kind of
more tawdry roles where i was like i'm
gonna squash the idea of this kid thing
and then right was on when i was on the
precipice of that i thought
oh i'm going to start getting typecast
as a bad girl and i
oh interesting to the film called ever
after and i was like
i want to grow up and become a young
woman
uh of substance in my life and this is a
persona i wanted to explore to switch
the
narrative on the kid thing yeah yeah and
now all of a sudden i'm a bad girl again
wait hold on
i don't want to be a bad girl i mean i
do but like
you know only to a certain extent and
it's a part of growing up
and that was a little bit extra for you
you